[Music]
do you guys know who these people are I
know for sure you know one of them yes
yeah oh we're gonna talk about their kid
yeah kid named Kyle kid named Kyle oh
they recently had their baby this is
Elon Musk and Grimes they've been dating
since Oh was he
pregnant her pregnant is very downloaded
something - yeah and so they recently
announced the birth of their son and
along with that they announced the name
she does music right yeah yeah yeah yeah
have any of you guys heard about this
name yeah I was just listening to his
recent podcast with Joe Rogan on the way
here a new one and like the way he talks
about the name it's so he pronounced it
cuz I stopped I didn't even get to that
part yeah he he talked about the
pronunciation oh he did I just heard him
break down the name and then he got kind
of like happy when he talks about the
middle part is named after an airplane
marking the archangel up program it's
him or was it a combination where they
work together on this name so crimes and
okay so first of all you on tweet it out
the name as a response to a fan right
and so this is oh wait this is a photo
of him the baby and then this is the
baby's name pronounced and then Grimes
later on she ends up posting this on
Twitter explaining each character but as
far as I know I still don't know how to
pronounce
I don't not that X is the unknown
variable yes what is it a my elven
spelling of my ex I love war okay yeah a
is pronounced ash ash yeah so it's X a
shady 12 or oh that's how you pronounce
X ashen 12 and he says it so
matter-of-factly oh yeah a 12 is just a
precursor to the S the S r17 aircraft I
named out the Archangel program it was
funny there was a that this guy was like
you know sometimes they tweet something
and then they they retweeted with the
comment be like holy [ __ ] right so this
guy last year was like wife you were
gonna name
kids like AE right and then he retweeted
was like what the [ __ ] it cuz the llamas
actually did the new trend because I
feel like celebrities like naming their
babies like after like like nature or
like some weird like mythical stuff that
blanket not yeah exactly now it's like
Michael Jackson it was premature
programming of a baby here we gotta do
this
I think eccentric people rich people
innovators they're always trying to find
a way to do something new and different
and start something like the names that
we have there are actually names of
powerful people or people from the past
or whatever that are significant and so
for them it's like why the [ __ ] would I
made my kid John I feel like weird
people are gonna be weird yeah and he's
[ __ ] weird if he didn't have money if
he didn't have money you think you would
do that he pops the water yeah he's just
really well he six other children
what are they named I'm sorry five other
children actually the very first child
passed my side so he was a baby when he
passed via with his previous wife so it
the first kid was Nevada Nevada
Alexander must that's already crazy
the other one was Damien or is Damien
musk Griffon musk which are twins a
unique and then triplets
Xavier musk saxon musk and KY musk it
got weirder and weirder
yeah jumped the gun though this is men's
and she's weird - it's just true maybe
before all the people he had to
compromise cuz of you but I don't know
about [ __ ] naming our kid you know 87
octane
I remember the first like celebrity
weird name I was like and everyone was
freaking out it's like years ago when
someone named their kid Apple and
everyone freaked out yeah I was going
with Paltrow yeah yeah
normal me now back then everyone freaked
out she actually this headline says that
she made a joke about it I want to name
a kid donut what happened to having a
paperclip that was never my choice knows
David deals like David doesn't name
Joe's kid room oh yeah goodness fine has
too many syllables or it's hard to say
PPC the problem with Elon Musk's kid's
name though is that he forgets his kids
gonna go to elementary school so he's
gonna end up getting his ass kicked
maybe he wants exactly that he goes I
got my ass kicked for being a nerd look
where I'm at today it's like that a
Johnny Cash song the boy named Sue oh
yeah yeah that was very homophobic song
it's pronouncing it joe rogan haven't
heard this I mean it's just X Don is so
weird and then the a E is like
pronounced a sh Y yeah watch Joe
laughing a 12 is my contribution oh
that's my contribution Archangel 12 now
with Professor Brian 471 dodge oh you
don't know so like just put it together
like what's the name thanks ash 12 X X X
ah [ __ ] 12 Ashish X ash 8 you're
probably gonna call the kid ash for
short that's so many syllables that's a
lot of cool nickname
what up X 12 how about a 1 even shorter
ha ha sauce what's cool is how long that
name is is still shorter than a tiny
that's my gong gong ringing cancer yeah
I haven't seen all the movies are they
coming up no people are going ham and
say the funniest things someone was like
always like I have birthdays he's gonna
have patch updates oh yeah
download game they're showing like it's
his like breakfast and it just is just a
bunch of air pods with milk in it dad
his life's gonna be so different
compared to like the regular person
because of just his name well I mean
obviously the celebrity coop I feel like
he's gonna have a really different kind
of upbringing celebrities have their own
schools right
yeah really powerful people yeah he's
gonna stand out within that skews think
he's gonna send his kid to a school I
think he's gonna be he's gonna go to a
factory 100% school with how many kids
he has like on a space nation he's I'm
my school he's going to a software
development company in gating [ __ ]
programs so it's probably gonna be
raised on Mars it's not have any other
kids or feel like with him naming his
kid that he's gonna be successful
forever because not everyone's gonna
know who he is he's already to get that
tension it's gonna be the exact opposite
worry and that's heroin exactly like the
kids gonna be so like so much pressure
for him to be so great implode because a
lot of people that are great their kids
actually don't do well like Michael
Jordan's kid is like it's hard to follow
them as Ron James's kids not that good
at they suck at life it's hard and it's
like a like [ __ ] leeches just cuz
that's amazing I back what I mean you're
gonna be amazing
no but they're just I think there's just
so much pressure that just it's just
it's just pressure or do you think it's
because like they're kinda like you
didn't have to hustle to be with that
Julia Jolie is a great example of
someone who had successful parents and
then she out successful them yes true
maybe I don't know that's rare it's
really rare to do that pretty known
actors right yeah well their era they're
also not the go it to like if we're near
the go that's true insane amount cuz
Michael Jackson's kids are probably
never gonna live up to his legendary not
a mom want to live in the shadows of
your parents yeah isn't that suck yeah I
mean like you're gonna have people like
us who say that you suck at life even
though you're completely successful
you're just not your parent all these
kids none of them are like poor none of
them are doing badly in life all of them
are probably have their own businesses
and [ __ ] and stuff like she's got it oh
yeah you seen her new house where they
look like oh my it's insane
think of the sidewalk in front like
there's a airplane runway what does it
look like you describe it to us
okay yes like he has freaking pools
everywhere and it looks like like it
kind of reminds me of Prince Eric's
castle from Little Mermaid mm-hmm it's
different than other Prince castles in
other yeah heavily be all this you know
what's better than except for jasmine
because they have like no I got played
cuz I googled house cuz the one that I
saw was on Twitter someone said that
that was his house cuz he owns a bunch
of them yeah he's selling I don't see
the one that I saw on Twitter and you
guys you guys are thinking too small you
know what's better than the house is a
country there's a man out there that's
kind of outshining his dad right now and
his grandpa in the man's name is kim
jong-un and I'm so jealous of him
because we're like the same age and I
could have had it but I did it and he
faked his death right now to [ __ ]
catch all the people that were
backstabbing him damn I was like that is
so crazy that move is clutch man or did
he make it or did they just replace or
is he just so Asian you can't even tell
he's sleeping or not that's true but
people say that was a body double but
what really came out was you know how
everyone thought he was dead he was
doing that to fish out
corruption within his you know political
Empire yeah I read something that he
didn't even have surgery that he was
just hiding from Corona verse yeah and
he was just chillin and drinking whiskey
and he was just like my to pucker guess
what I'm gonna piss you guys out that
was playing mafia with everybody so how
do you do it he like him I just hit and
the people are like I [ __ ] I'm a
traitor
and they came out yeah I think like he
was probably if he is about to die he
wanted to see who was trying to
consolidate power within his group he
assassinated his uncle for the same
reason Oh what so has there been
assassinations happening in North Korea
I don't know about that but when he took
power he did assassinate his uncle
though I thought he assassinated uncle
because his uncle took power that was uh
because within the family line his uncle
would have been the successor if Kim
Jong Hyun died it's like reverse Simba
and [ __ ] scar accept what scars the
baby at this point there were talks that
his sister might take it because he
killed his own brother too
he assassinated him in Malaysia cause I
was his brother and his brothers dad or
yeah yeah his uncle so is he gonna kill
his sister no I don't think so I think
this is my theory behind it right is I
think him and his sister are [ __ ]
homies and good baby
poopy gluteal a verse um she's been a
part of the government for a while and
she's an active member right so more
ruthless than him
yeah I heard so too scary she looks cool
but I was like that's right that's my
chance the first moment that Kim jong-un
is announced dead I'm [ __ ] going to
North Korea I'm gonna [ __ ] propose to
her love me dude and we're gonna rule
that [ __ ] together you know well
come on in a ball gag for the rest
amen would you be the number two of one
of the most powerful dictators in the
whole entire world not after a woman not
if they're a woman man yes women are
bared they're dangerous [ __ ] I am a
[ __ ] but what I mean you get what if
right you don't have the responsibility
of actually doing the work and leading
so you get to dress up and play the role
of a dictator people love you and [ __ ]
and maybe she might die of sickness or
something and then you can finally take
over as her husband or what if she's so
ruthless I was like if I die
[ __ ] you die too
boy am i if I have to [ __ ] be buried
alive with the Empress then I might as
well but for the time being you at least
I get to play dress-up and where I just
want to be a dictator with those 20
[ __ ] medals be a part of a country oh
man is she's not bad-looking dude I
don't know I'm just kind of where do you
get nothing like like the Queen of
England her man he doesn't even get like
a king title or anything yeah what's his
name he doesn't I see no one knows I
[ __ ] know he's gonna put a successful
thanks Philip Prince Philip yeah that's
a yeah not even a king Charles it's
always a Philip Sleeping Beauty I think
is named after like the prince they
named him after him that's her husband
yeah I thought the Queen of England
didn't even have no husband yeah well
how come he can't be the king then cuz
she doesn't want to give it to him she
was offended cuz she's because she's a
woman she's strong the women are strong
that's what that's what will happen to
you Joe you gonna have no name in a ball
gag in your mouth
I rather be number two next to a strong
woman that could give me the world then
a number one and a broke-ass [ __ ]
how about that but North Korea it's
amazing that's true
[Music]
[Music]